today's quiet calm betrays the scenes of
panic
two years ago when hundreds of thousands
of Renga crossed the river naff in a
desperate attempt to seek safety they
are safe now but nothing has been
resolved nor has six children he was
part of the Exodus in August of 2017
they asked if you want to go back to
Burma I said no they asked me why I told
them that the houses were burnt our
family members were raped and killed
this is why we suffered so much and came
here how can we go back without knowing
that we will be safe there's been a
renewed effort to get some of the
refugees to go back to Myanmar but with
no guarantee of what will happen when
they get there
no one has so far agreed to return the
scale of this camp is like nothing
you've ever seen it is the biggest
refugee camp in the world around a
million Ranga living in these camps
across southeastern Bangladesh but what
does that number really mean well it's
more or less the population of Islamabad
or Oslo it is a city of refugees without
the infrastructure needed to cope many
aid agencies work here in that sense it
is a global effort but it's Bangladesh
that's hosting the rahaga
and it's made it very clear this is a
temporary solution and it's a population
that keeps expanding this is a very
dynamic population we have been about
100 new children born every day that
makes about 33,000 35,000 people being
added every year so it keeps doing the
young won't remember much about what
happened but the older ones know that
the killings the rapes the burning of
homes in August of 2017 was only the
latest chapter in what's been decades of
persecution against their people
Naseer Hussain is a camp leader this is
his third time as a refugee in
Bangladesh I'm 65 years old I came here
as a refugee in 1978 then again in 1992
then I went back now I'm a refugee again
in 2017
I've spent 30 years of my life as a
refugee I want to go home
if the Burmese accept our demands we'll
go back right away what they want is to
be officially recognized as Ranga as
citizens of Myanmar with rights freedom
of movement and security what they want
is to go back home but the reality is
they are not wanted there most of their
homes no longer exist Bangladesh is
categoric it can't host them forever
it's not clear what or where their
future will be